hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on the outer worlds
again and today we're gonna be talking
about what you see in the title
basically Shila the social media manager
at obsidian was kind of talking about
the game Ward's nomination stuff sadly
for the game Awards they didn't win any
of the nominations they were part of but
of course that's still pretty impressive
that a game that they released month ago
has even gotten four nominations so that
once again that's still very impressive
what they say here to those to all of
those who voted for us in the game
Awards you are all fantastic and we are
so grateful for your support the
reception of the Auto Worlds has been
unbelievable to see and and even being
nominated means a lot however the
journey isn't over yet and we were
excited to announce that we will be
expanding the story through the DLC next
year details will be made at a later
date which means yes the outer worlds
will be getting a dlc as for what planet
and what's gonna happen nobody really
knows but I think it's still kind of
exciting that we are going to be getting
somewhat of a DLC and I mean obviously
they did say that they did plan on
making DLCs I mean I think even one of
the people one of the creative directors
said that they wanted to make a sequel
even though the game hadn't even
released it but of course it's always
nice to get confirmation from the
developers themselves if we're going to
be getting something and this is pretty
much what that is and like I said as for
when this is going to come out nobody
knows as for what's it's going to be in
it no one also knows that as well but
you know it's still pretty exciting to
know that this is going to exist
hopefully it's going to have to deal
with one of the many planets that we
have yet to visit - and I believe I
forgot so many of the different names of
those planets that are just sitting
there blatantly in the solar system that
we can't even visit hopefully those are
what those are going to be maybe even I
think at least in my opinion my most
anticipated DLC for this game would be a
discussion and a lore video about the
earth and kind of what's happening with
that I would love to see what's going on
with that situation yeah let me know
what you guys think about this stuff in
the comments below I didn't want to make
a super giant video talking about this
but I didn't want to let you guys know
that outer worlds were beginning a dlc
at some point and i think it's going to
be pretty exciting so keep Locke on the
channel here so I can keep you guys up
to date we'll see how that goes but that
guys take care
like the VP doing - uh subscribe if
you're new and peace out guys I'll see
you in another video
you